the inventor Nikola Tesla dreamt of
wireless power among his work in the
realm of electricity he built a coil
later named the Tesla coil which could
illuminate lamps from across a room and
throw the occasional bolt of lightning
at the nearest conductor Tesla coils
remained popular today though often for
their ability to put on a fantastic
lightning show Nikola Tesla believed in
wireless power with such an enthusiasm
that with the financing of JP Morgan he
constructed a giant apparatus the
Wardenclyffe tower at his lab in
Shoreham Long Island in 1901 this was
before the world was wired way back then
when people were thinking about
electricity and how people might use it
I don't think it ever occurred to them
that people would string wires all over
the country the early on people were
thinking about transferring power
wirelessly the idea to send wireless
power around the globe we love
electricity so much human beings love it
so much that we've been willing to put
in wired power everywhere I'm sure if
you go back to Tesla's time he wanted to
do things wirelessly and experimented
with it because he thought who would be
crazy enough to put in the trillions of
dollars of infrastructure that we've put
in more than a century after Tesla's
Tower were still tethered to the wall
why tricity a start-up in Watertown
Massachusetts is one of several
companies hoping to revive Tesla's dream
and it's doing so by developing a
business in wireless power transfer
there's power everywhere in the world
except that last few feet from the wall
to the center of the room that is the
last part to go wireless
and once that last part goes wireless
this projector can receive its power
from a source that's almost a meter
below here's how it works
run an electric current through a coil
of copper wire and the coil will produce
a short-range magnetic field place a
second coil within this field and an
electric current will flow through it
the magnetic field has transferred
electrical power from one coil to the
other this principle is called induction
and it has been understood for more than
a century induction is what charges a
wireless electric toothbrush for example
and it works well over extremely short
distances
hold the coils apart and the power
transfer ceases it turns out that the
trick to longer distance power transfer
is the same principle an opera singer
uses to shatter a wine glass from across
the room
it's called resonance for the opera
singer when the frequency of the sound
wave matches the unique resonant
frequency of a glass the acoustic energy
is converted to kinetic energy at the
highest possible efficiency the energy
then builds inside the glass until it
shatters the coils that why tricity uses
to transfer power wirelessly are
magnetic resonators first a rapidly
oscillating electric current is applied
to a coil at its specific resonant
frequency this creates a magnetic field
in the region around the coil tune a
second coil to the same resonant
frequency as the source and it will
couple resonating anywhere within that
region and converting the oscillating
magnetic field into an electrical
current within the second coil
this response is called highly coupled
magnetic resonance and it hasn't been
done before
by attaching the second coil to a device
such as the battery of an electric car
or a mobile phone this current can be
made to do useful work the source can be
either of centimeters or meters away
from the device being powered and can
deliver power through walls or around
metal obstacles the power can even be
distributed across multiple devices at
once so by a simple trick of physics
power is transferred wirelessly Nikola
Tesla would be proud you could put these
resonators in walls and floors and
ceilings and would allow you to power
virtually anything in your house you
could place it under the counters
imagine you could just go home and you
if you carry a purse you throw your
purse onto the counter and you don't
even have to think about taking your
phone or your camera or your PDA out of
your purse it just charges because the
surface underneath your counter is
energized by tricity is developing a
system not a specific product and as a
result they have many different
platforms on display at once in white
Rissa t's demonstration rooms a
flat-screen television is powered using
a resonator hidden in its base laptops
with their batteries removed and
replaced by resonators flicker on and
flash lights glow when placed next to a
source concealed behind a bulletin board
the system can even be extended beyond
the range of a single source using
passive resonators like this one by this
method many cabinet lights are lit well
beyond the expected range of the single
source below maybe no surprise you get
the light to come on even inside the
cabinet way up in the cabinet you can
almost think of it as though the energy
is held by the structure itself we're
not sending electricity through the air
and it doesn't radiate out into space
it's when's another kind of a copper
coil or wire coil comes in the vicinity
of that field that it can sense it and
then capture it and turn that magnetic
field into a into a current so safety is
definitely one of the issues that people
think about and ask us about so one of
the things that makes it very safe is
the fact that we're using the magnetic
field to transfer the power humans look
almost like free space to a magnetic
field in addition to that you know we
have a lot of you know electronic
devices that we use every day and so
there are well-established standards for
what the fields around those devices can
look like and all the technology that we
develop will conform to those same kind
of standards the intensity the magnetic
fields we're using by the way are about
the same intensity as that of the earth
most people don't think of it but the
earth is it we're in a magnetic field
right now the applications of wireless
power in a wired world are endless and
rethinking infrastructure may be decades
away a simple first step could be
removing costly batteries from things as
mundane as computer accessories and
instead placing a small wireless
resonator in the computer itself
tackling waste by centimeters at first
at the end of the day if you can find
something that is convenient for people
and saves energy that's the killer app
wireless power has in fact been
available for decades just waiting for a
clever user to snatch it out of the air
it exists in radio and television
signals and is available 24 hours a day
Josh Smith and Al Anson sample of Intel
labs in Seattle Washington are pointing
their devices at television antennas and
powering small but useful gadgets solely
off of the energy that carries TV
programs
well there's energy all around us TV
signals which you normally think of as
just information also have a little bit
of energy content one of their projects
is named warp and it stands for wireless
ambient radio power according to them we
are just entering the boom years of
energy harvesting we're receiving energy
from the TV towers that are for coal
is out that way they're putting out a
megawatt of power this TV antenna
picks up the radio signal
through this coax cable here little
rectifying circuit turns the radio
signal it's a regular DC voltage just
like a battery would put out and right
now it's powering this kitchen
thermometer so as we turn this away from
the TV tower at a certain point it's
going to lose power now it's off because
it's not facing the TV tower we bring it
back pops pops back on as soon as it's
got enough
so here's the TV tower transmitting
tower here we're up here near the
University of Washington these circles
show the amount of power you'd expect to
be able to get as a function of distance
so kind of anywhere in the city of
Seattle you'd expect to be able to get
up to you know 100 microwatts compared
to solar course Solar is a really good
energy harvesting source but it's only
available for 12 hours a day
TV towers have been broadcasting about
the same amount of energy or power for
you know decades but what's changed
recently is that the power requirements
of the smallest devices have gotten low
enough that you can actually power them
off of a TV tower now Josh Smith says
wireless ambient radio power harvesting
might yield a milliwatts or so to a
device that's not very much
it would require twenty milliwatts to
keep a mobile phone in standby mode but
it might be enough to perform some
useful low-power functions does it sound
like much but you know that's actually a
lot for four sensors you know you may
not be able to make a cell phone call
but maybe you can press you know a 911
that does nothing but sends this you
know one very small but very important
data packet I think many consumer
electronic devices will start to have a
little kind of reptilian brain that you
know perhaps never powers down and
perhaps that is being powered off of
ambient RF signals you know there's the
annoying flashing VCR clock I don't know
if people have VCRs anymore but so that
may be another solution to the problem
but no reason why digital clocks in the
future should ever run out of energy I
think if you wait a few years it'll
actually get really practical and I
don't see why you wouldn't see it all
over the place amazing to think of it
some of
and the potential for us to actually
harvested thank you City
this is arguably not the most useful
thing ever but I think the potential is
really there
makes it very
nikola tesla's tower was torn down in
1916 mr. Morgan his financier was
uninterested in broadcasting electricity
that people could so easily harvest for
free instead we strung wires and built
meters Tesla knew that wireless power
transfer was possible but he never saw
his dream realized
it seems that soon enough we will The
Economist